does it all make sense yes
you okay yes sir all right i didn't know
what you think it was funny well no no
you're fine i was just curious you
started laughing
oh yeah what you got lightning
[Applause]
alcohol
gotcha glossy eyes i can smell that call
when i walked up to the car where's he
from california what's he doing right
here he said he's going to comic con
west virginia
that's a driver yeah he's uh might take
a couple hours
yeah i got a couple lane violations on
him he actually
rolled up on me pretty quick got behind
me
got back over i guess he realizes that i
was a deputy he
slowed down a little bit i waited for
him to pass got a couple of hours you
know i'm not stopping okay was he over
the dashlane solid fog on both uh white
one quite long a couple of times yep
okay all right i'm gonna make contact
with him
have you ran a plate
yeah i i got the return back on again
hey trooper bean stay at highway patrol
um so it's my understanding you're going
to west virginia yes sir
okay gotcha um where are you coming from
tonight
um
cincinnati cincinnati okay um what part
of cincinnati
what the airport
what should i say
i know who you are i was gonna say i
thought that looked like you okay were
you out are you doing something in
ironton
oh yes sir okay what were you doing in
ironton well no uh uh huntington first
okay i'm getting sick
okay gotcha are you doing like your tour
right now yes sir okay did you drive out
here yeah
okay all right well i put to tonight
you drove here from cincinnati but
you're going to huntington right now yes
sir are you doing your tour right now
yes when you do uh your tour for
huntington
not tonight i'm sure it's too early in
the morning
okay all right gotcha um how much we had
to drink tonight one one beer or one
a shot of liquor what no no one beer one
beer okay um i'm just gonna ask you step
out and run you through a couple things
make sure you're safe to drive okay
you didn't tell me
okay
it's gonna be the second car back okay
yes sir
i'm going to have you walk a little left
i don't want to get hit by this car okay
let's walk right over there by that
front license plate
just stand right there for me back it up
for you okay
all right mr kekner you can come right
over here for me
do you wear contacts or glasses or
anything i don't okay would you consider
yourself in overall good health
would you consider yourself
are you on any medications currently
and then any history of head injuries
that cost you day-to-day issues
all right you're a bit taller than me if
you want you can kind of sit on my hood
there while i run you through a couple
things okay that way you put you a
little more eye level than me
all right perfect so what i'll ask you
to do
is follow the tip of my pen with your
eyes and eyes on it okay i don't want to
move your head or anything
that'd be the tip of the pen right there
take a second to blink and we'll keep
going
let me take a second to blink and we'll
keep going
i'll tell you what um just for a sake of
this i'll have you again stand up here
i hate to ask you are you able to kill
your rear deck
we'll stay put i was gonna move you but
you gotta take another seat there
that's that one
there's lights in your face there
all right
same thing tip of my pen thank you
[Applause]
thank you
all right same thing but someone want to
go up okay
all right next thing i'll ask you to do
mr peck now i asked you to come down
this way for me
i'm just standing
right there on my light and i'll have
you turn and face my car right here
what i'll ask you to do yes sir we'll
take let's actually back up a couple
more steps just to give you a little
extra room
so for what i'm asking you to do on this
one is i'm going to ask you to take a
series of non-health test steps turn
yourself around and take another night
back i'm going to give you more details
but the reason i tell you that right now
is it's up to you i know you have boots
on if you want to take it with your
boots on that's fine if you want to do
it with your boots off that's fine i
just want to give you the option
what would you like to do
as
i am okay all right so what i'll ask you
to do is imagine a straight line going
from you to my front license plate are
you able to imagine that line yes sir
all right what i'll ask you to do is
take your left foot and put on that line
you're imagining for me then take your
right foot put it in front of your left
foot
touching heel to toe
touch your heel toe just like that you
actually got a touch
okay so see how your heel is kind of
behind your toe there
actually yep all right and then i'll
have you put your hands down to your
side don't move tom told you to do you
understand what i'm going to ask you to
do sir is take a series of nine hill to
toe steps along that line you're
imagining turn yourself around take
another nine back you understand so far
sure all right i'm gonna show you what
it looks like that's okay you stand
right there get back in that starting
position for me right foot in front of
left touching heel to toe
hands down to your side
okay
that's all right you're gonna get back
in the starting position so you're gonna
be in the starting position that you're
in that's the way i'm standing as well
and it'll look like this one yes sir two
three i took three heel to toe steps
you'll take nine on that ninth step i
want you to keep your front foot
touching the ground use your other foot
to turn yourself around with a series of
small steps
just like so
once you turn yourself down i have you
take another nine back
one
two
three again i took three heel to toe
steps you'll take nine hillary two steps
you have any questions about what i
showed you nope you understand the
instructions yes sir all right things i
want you to do as you do this
you must look down your feet count your
steps out loud
nine
nine steps yeah you get back in a
certain position so look down to your
feet
i'm okay count your steps out loud
i want you to keep your hands down your
side and don't stop until you've
completed the instructions do you
understand no yes sir all right you may
begin if you understand the instructions
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight nine
then you'll turn yourself around like i
showed you and do the other nine back
one
two
three
four
five
two
just like that all right the next thing
i'll ask you to do sir just stand on my
light there for me
turn and face me
all right just stand with your feet
together hands down your side don't move
so i've told you too do you understand
all right what i'm gonna ask you to do
when i tell you to begin left or right
foot it doesn't matter to me it's
totally your choice whichever one you'd
like take that foot of your choice hold
it approximately six inches above the
ground
parallel with the ground both legs nice
and straight no bending your knee keep
your hands down your side and count the
series of one thousands like so one
thousand one one thousand two one
thousand three one thousand four
and so on until i told you to stop you
have any questions about the
instructions no does it all make sense
yes sir
you okay yes sir all right i didn't know
what you think it was funny well no no
you're fine i'm just curious you started
laughing so that's okay if you
understand the instructions you may
begin
so
go ahead yeah ask whatever you want to
put it up
yeah just like i showed you so you hold
it approximately six inches above the
ground parallel with the ground both
legs nice and straight no bending in
your knee look down your foot and
counting the series of one thousands
like so one thousand one one thousand
two thousand one thousand three one
thousand four and so on until i've told
you to stop that's what we'll start just
yet don't start just yet
do you understand the instructions now
it all makes sense now yes sir okay you
may begin when you're ready 1001.
i'm sorry i'm picking up resume where
you left off
2001. two
three
five six
seven
eight nine
you keep picking up reason where you
left off yes sir
you remember where you left off
well five okay poor actually
all right so you can go ahead and stop
the last thing i'll ask you to just walk
to the front of my car for me
yeah you can walk just anyway
just keep facing my car would you put
your hands on your back
141 on that buck henry zebra henry 86.78
and under the rest
operating vehicle
do you have a watch or anything you'd
like me to take off of you before i hang
out
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
handcuff you miranda's you provide you
have your rights
nope okay do you understand what
impairment is
okay you've been arrested for operating
the vehicle while impaired
have you ever been arrested for the eye
before sir sir when was the last time uh
december
uh
2021 this past december
sure okay what state was that in
calcutta okay you have the right to
remain silent anything you say can will
be used against you in court you have
the right to talk to a lawyer for advice
before we ask you any questions and i
have a lawyer present with your very
question you're unable to pay a lawyer
one will be appointed for you prior to
any questioning if you so desire you
wish to answer questions now without a
lawyer president you have the right to
stop answering questions at any time you
also have the right to stop answering
any time until you talk to them or you
understand the right search